que l'aventure commence faut qu'on
trouve la bonne rame couchette 11 à 56 à
51 ma petite maison est ici du coup
voilà mon petit lit petit bouchon
d'oreille pour si j'ai des petits
partenaires qui ronflent
[Musique]
je prends le train en couchette de nuit
pour aller à Saint-Raphaël on part pour
à peu près 12 heures de trajet j'ai
réservé mon voyage via SNCF Connect donc
j'ai tout simplement écrit Paris
Saint-Aygulf et j'ai directement trouvé
les trains de nuit du coup à des prix
qui sont aussi assez attractifs
l'application elle est hyper intuitive
donc c'est assez facile pour réserver
les billets un autre détail aussi qui
est intéressant pour le coup c'est qu'on
voit aussi les arrêts du train là par
exemple je sais que ça fait Paris -
Marseille d'une traite et que je vais
pas être dérangé en fait sur la nuit les
raisons de prendre le train c'est vrai
que c'est un aspect écologique on se
rend compte qu'il fait plus chaud qu'il
y a beaucoup de voitures qui a beaucoup
de pollution si on peut faire ce petit
geste et que finalement ça nous coûte
rien de plus je me dis bah pourquoi pas
les utiliser
c'est plus convivial ici du coup
est-ce qu'on va avoir des enfants dans
la couchette qui n'ont pas envie de
dormir les gens ça y est sont couchés du
coup je vais essayer ma couchette
déjà ça a la taille de mon corps
franchement c'est hyper confortable
et en plus quand on est dans la RAM en
fait on entend beaucoup moins le bruit
il mange plus qu'à mettre le petit
masque et comme ça
je te souhaite une très bonne nuit à
demain
[Musique]
alors cette première expérience
finalement il y a pas tant de bruit que
ça ça va encore le couchage et vraiment
convenable pour le coup je vais aller
dans les toilettes on a une petite
lingette et essayer de faire la totale
avant d'arriver sur mon lieu de vacances
mais bon c'est parti
ça y est bien arrivé à Saint-Raphaël on
va rejoindre la famille aller à la
piscine et puis voilà j'ai profité des
vacances quoi